[Music]
um hello everyone thank you for being
here and thank you all for joining so
maggie i gotta start with you because
you thought up this little adventure for
everyone to
set out on
why
and how did you find elena ferrante's
novel and then decide to make it into
this beautiful movie that everyone just
saw
miss caruso welcome thank you
yeah
mommy get up
you don't have kids
yes i have two daughters
hey your mommy's your girl you're my big
girl
she's driving me great
it's funny i promised all the people on
stage with me that i would
i would find a new way of explaining
i mean i it's she she stunned me when i
read her books i don't know how many
people out here have read ferrante even
if not this one if you read the
neapolitan novels
um i mean it's got to be a few of you
out there that read them i mean they
were like flying off the shelves i think
because she
was talking about things that had
not been spoken about before
um
she
you know i think
especially as women in the world
there's so many things about our
experience that i i
i hadn't heard talked about all that
much and when i read her books i thought
i mean i didn't even know i thought some
of the things that that
that she was talking about and i thought
you know it
really would be incredible to have to
hear those things spoken out loud not um
alone in my room with her book like i
think many other women were
you know we're also having a similar
experience but in a situation like this
you know in a movie theater is
both a personal experience and a
communal experience
and
you know what if you could hear some of
these truths that she was talking about
in her books you know actually spoken
out loud um
sitting next to
your mother or your husband or your
your daughter
um
and so
i think that's what appealed to me about
her work in general in fact originally i
wanted to adapt a different book i'd
read the neapolitan novels which are the
probably the most popular and then i
read this book days of abandonment and i
was like this is a perfect book
and
i went to the publisher and asked them
if i could have the rights and they said
you know they're really complicated
they're tied up and you know this
italian
you know film company owns them in
perpetuity and uh they said would you
what about the lost daughter
and i read it in a weekend and i was
like yes it's the same it's the same
she's she's being just as honest and
talking about all the same things in
this book
as as she is in all of her books
the difficulty in this book i think and
the real risk well there are a lot of
risks but one of them was
and like are you guys a group of actors
is that really what you are okay so we
should end up talking about that mostly
but so one of the things though is that
like in this um
in this book of course there's this this
sort of less than 20-year age difference
in the um
in the flashbacks
and cinematically what do you do with
that
um
that was the real question when i went
to adapt it but i thought
i
i thought at the time i just thought i'm
just going to write it the way i imagine
it as if it could be anything as if an
actress could morph and be
you know
28 and 48. or what however 46 she is in
the movie um
and then you know when it came down to
we should talk about acting right and we
can move into
they want more well
ultimately we did the adaptation and
then i thought
well i did the adaptation and i thought
what would i do will i will i age an
actress you know that's so goofy
i mean there are people who've done it
well i just recently saw la vie on rose
with marion cotillard i was like okay
that's cool that's amazing what she did
but
i think this would be sort of goofy to
try to like trick people that you know
or or even um
have two actresses and have them like
try to look exactly alike i was like
they don't care if they look exactly
like i thought the thing to do
is to have
a kind of poetic agreement
with the audience
okay of course these are going to be two
fully formed actresses it's going to be
olivia coleman and jesse buckley they're
obviously different people
but
can we agree for the purposes of telling
the story that they're the same
you know and like
yeah and they were i mean and jessie i
remember telling jessie like if you want
to bleach your hair blonde i don't care
you know i you can do whatever you want
and and
really all that matters is that their
souls are
connected
and then they could be utterly free as
actors they could do whatever they
wanted you know which is what we all
want
to have freedom thank you thank you
for sharing that um
dakota
you have done such amazing work up until
now and this is very different than
we've seen
of you before
uh later
which you'll see by olivia coleman the
perfect olivia coleman excuse me i have
to show respect um she
um she sees a lot of her younger self
than you uh in the in the movie what
sort of discussions did you have with
olivia to build up that relationship on
screen that you guys had this connection
that eventually
gets to that place in which
you find the doll and
all hell breaks loose
we didn't have those discussions
we just like talked [ __ ] and
looked at furniture websites and
like
figured out where we were going to have
dinner
but really created a
like an actual an actual bond it wasn't
we weren't trying to the thing that's so
amazing and what maggie was just talking
about is like
always we see
different actors playing the same people
in films but like
duh we know they're not the same person
and it i think the the fact that maggie
let that go away without forcing anybody
to look the same or wear the same you
know eye colored contacts which like
it's it makes it almost as as though you
you assume your audience is not as smart
as they are like they can't figure out
the story on their own
but
only only until recently we were in an
interview did maggie realize that they
had the same color eyes olivia and jesse
which was amazing to watch not just the
same color like really the same yeah
yeah beautiful it was amazing
but it but it was like
olivia and i created a connection on our
own that is from me and olivia not this
false
relationship that then translated on
like it was so real everything in this
movie is so real
there's not there wasn't like you know
let's figure out how to pretend to make
this feel right or feel real it just was
thank you right and you guys know as
actors
that so much i think of the work is
what is the actual relationship between
you when you get there
sometimes you really have to pretend
like sometimes you're working with
people where you're like [ __ ] man
this is rough and you're boring as [ __ ]
or like you're an [ __ ] and i don't
get along with you
or like you're
you know overbearing and you're trying
to direct me and that we have a director
or whatever it is and
sometimes you have to create a whole
imaginary world which is like
also amazing
but because maggie
i haven't had this experience as an
actress
where
being directed by a woman actor by
another actress who knows what it feels
like to be an actor acting
where
nothing had to be
manipulated it was almost like
everything
we were so safe
to do
all the extreme versions of everything
and to go super super tender and super
soft and then super ugly
and
there wasn't a moment where i felt
like oh my god
actually that's not true there were a
lot of moments where i was like oh my
god
are people gonna think i'm a horrible
person
or i'm a [ __ ] i'm like gonna be a
horrible mother
but obviously no because it's a movie
but
but it there were
it made me feel safe enough to go there
now that's i think the biggest thing
that i that
happened sorry
stop talking
uh no thank you thank you for that peter
uh you have had such an amazing career
that we've followed for for so long i
think you're one of the greatest that we
have that are working today
[Applause]
uh i'm going to refer back to a
interview i had with maggie a while ago
and you being her muse her first movie
and what it was like
for her to direct you
how was it for you
to have her
uh
write this role for you specifically
with you in mind
and give you this opportunity
you know she told me she wrote all of
the mail roles for me
[Laughter]
um i love how he directed it right at
paul too he was like just want to let
you know
that was mine i am you
um
i mean there's nothing better if any i
mean
if any of you have the opportunity
somehow to do this i highly recommend it
um
no i mean
you get tired of challenging yourself
at least i do you know and it's very
easy you know you wonder why so many
actors that
give a good performance here and there
don't always give a great performance
because it's
it's very difficult it's like being an
athlete in some ways maintaining a
certain level and
level of focus
and i've certainly gone in and out over
the years of
the amount that i can focus in the
amount that i care and it's you know it
waxes and wanes
but um
there's no
bullshitting your wife
and
and uh
so i was really nervous i was really
nervous to play this small part in this
movie you know i was like i only worked
on it for three days but
i
i mean how many books did i read i like
tried to turn myself into an
intellectual which i'm decidedly not i
actually listened to maggie
this is true when we arrived in greece
in august for pre-production we didn't
start filming until the end of september
i read
like
many many books but one of the things i
read
was anna karenina while listening to
maggie
narrate it because she does the book on
tape which i really
really recommend
especially for the boring passages she
really spices him up
um
but uh
no i it was like i remember
showing up to do the the lecture which
for me felt like a huge huge thing to
try to
i mean
i'm really i can't emphasize this enough
i'm like really not an intellectual
i might come across that way for some
reason maybe it's somebody with my voice
or your beard it's my beard
um
corduroys it's the karate horizon the
clark's wallabies
he's really trying hard
really
what does the audience think i feel like
we should all start polling they're like
well what makes peter look like a genius
no please no i mean i've been i i i
usually don't care i usually just go
whatever they'll they'll make me seem
like a smart enough person to be the
guy who can operate the nuclear power
plant on board the submarine
um
but it's not me i i was horrible in
school but anyway
doing that lecture scene with maggie and
watch feeling her watch me feeling so
observed in every detail
knowing that i was being really really
listened to
i mean
if every director could just listen like
that
i mean we would all give
the most beautiful performances every
time the truth is they aren't always
listening and we are sensitive people
and when they're not listening we stop
talking you know
stop talking and start crying
shut up
uh paul
uh i feel like i need a fire
extinguisher because you're on fire
these days uh with normal people
in the last uh yes please
uh
got yourself an emmy nomination out of
that and then now you're working with
this cast
and you're this
eye
to
a lot of what we see happen we see we
learn more about nina because of you we
learned more about uh leyda because of
you uh can you speak about your
involvement and how
you saw yourself play in this story
yeah i think it was uh about trying not
to over complicate
over complicated but played as
truthfully as possible and i was in the
best hands with maggie to guide that and
not um
try to make things out of stuff that
isn't there and i think sometimes that's
a hard thing to do because you want to
make yourself busy especially it was my
first film so you're looking at
okay
first day on sets with dakota the next
days with olivia it's kind of like sink
or swim or it feels like that
but um
i think approaching it was just as you
said it's try to observe everything and
let that feeling change from take to
take which maggie totally allows and um
for me in general the project was just
such a
a dream because you're working with
people at the top of their game
and
it's it's thrilling and it's terrifying
and i think when those two things clash
together it um
it results in something that i'm
incredibly proud of so yeah
thank you
uh meg you have to give you the
opportunity right now to talk about
this great ensemble um i'm sorry for any
other movie you'll make in the future
because your first one included olivia
coleman dakota johnson peter sarsgaard
ed harris paul maskell
jesse jesse buckley
[Music]
that's a dream cast for
steven spielberg and then here you are
on your first outing
because you're an actor and such a
brilliant actress i have to add um did
you
did you treat and allow them that
freedom that you would want on set when
you were uh
when
when you still work and how did you get
them to the place that they can deliver
these performances as as great as they
do
well i think um
yeah i i i in many many ways i am a
beginner
um
and then in some ways of course i'm not
and um
i've worked with many many directors and
then i think about like
television you know which i did for
three years on the dues i have a new
director every three weeks you know
and
i've worked with directors who were
brutal
and i've worked with directors now and
then
who were full of love
and curiosity about me and respect for
me
as an artist alongside them
and
i know
how valuable that is i mean in some ways
i sometimes that thought of it like
you know when you're a child and some
injustice happens in your family and you
think like even just something small
like i did not take that cookie or you
know whatever it is and you think when i
when i run my life it will not be like
this
and i felt
i felt very much like that about how i
was gonna run my set because i have to
say i'm sure as actors every single okay
i'll just tell this like little story
our friend worked on this film or the
television thing recently peter and a
friend of ours who was working with a um
and he's very seasoned actor and he was
having a rough time but very very
seasoned but then he then this other
actor came who's like 80 who's like done
tons of things and walked down to set
and the director said okay um so you're
gonna start here and walk over to the
window and then you're going to start at
the typewriter and then go over to the
refrigerator and this 80 year old doctor
said well
this sucks
you know and and we all know this
feeling where you're like oh this person
is not at all interested in me and then
what you have to do as an actor i think
is you just protect your little space i
find maybe particularly as a woman i i
don't know though maybe not that
people are
some directors maybe many directors i
i think maybe many
are not
interested in all of our ideas you know
and so you're like okay fine i've
learned i'm i'm you know i've been
acting a long time okay fine we don't
you don't have to be interested in all
my ideas but i need these ones in order
to make the scene work
and so you figure out how to be quiet or
i heard meryl streep one time say you
know you just you just offer your idea
or the thing you need with a spoonful of
sugar
and i took that to heart
and i just thought on my set
i just don't want to waste everybody's
time with that [ __ ]
like
some of the jessie and the little girls
wrote the song peel it like a snake
you know like i keep
all of these actors at every single one
of my actors
i wanted to work with them because not
only because i could tell okay these are
these are actors with a
with a storytelling mind these are
actors who are going to exponentially
lift my project and not only that also
okay olivia coleman jesse peter paul
dakota i see who they are i mean i
didn't know you that well paul but like
i i
i know what i like
you know and i i didn't even see normal
people it was before normal people and
he made a tape for me and i was like
done
and i could see
because it's what i do like okay for
dakota to play nina for paul to play
well for
peter to play professor hardy for olivia
to play later jesse everyone
it's not just that i haven't seen them
do it before
i haven't but it's that i can tell
that they have to like grow a little
in order to do it like really well
and that's what i look for in a part for
myself as an actress so that's what i
was casting for
and then
if you cast like that and you respect
and are curious about the people who are
in your film
it's easy to love them
and to watch them like i mean come on
this is an amazing gift to watch them
then you're watching people if you love
them and they feel safe
you're watching people not pretend like
they're learning what they need to learn
in order to play this character well
you're watching them actually learn what
they need to learn in order to play the
character well which is
to me anyway like endlessly fascinating
and
compelling thank you
i
i have a question for the actors and
i've seen this
film once with the audience and this is
the second audience so
forgive me for for asking this because i
don't
i've never really known and i hate this
like criticism like the film critic like
line of this if this is gonna be a
gender
split of of a movie in terms of the
reception like does it affect men
different than it does for women because
this is obviously through the eyes of a
woman and we see
women portrayed so honestly and raw in a
way that
conventionally american audiences are
not used to or cinematic audiences
did you feel any of that or did you have
that same type of hesitation
uh when you took on the role did you
think this was made
for one gender versus another did you
feel that at all
no
i no i
i didn't i think i feel like
this woman can tell this truth in this
way and
i've also witnessed
many not many but a few men
recognize these women more than you
reckon more than they recognize the
the usual arc with female archetypes you
see on film you know like oh that's
that's my mother or that's my
uh my sister my my wife but
no i didn't i didn't feel like it was a
i don't feel like it's just for women
this film i think it's for everyone but
i do think it's
it's a conversation
that women
it's a god it's women make having a
conversation making a film about women
having a conversation
and it's
so important i don't i don't know that a
man could have told this story this way
but a man could have told this story
peter or paul did you want to add
anything to them i thought it was the
most commercial movie i'd ever read
[Laughter]
everyone has a mother everyone has a
mother not everyone has spice or
something from doom
you know everyone has a mother
i agree everybody has a mother that was
my first response
i love peter um
let me let me ask this is a kind of like
my wrap-up question here now
you know we're we're here
um
by the way big shout out to your
cinematographer uh uh as a helene helen
helena
my god
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous um
we are left now with many feelings at
the end of the movie and uh you know
i think olivia coleman in many ways says
the line of the movie like you know when
they when when nina's asking her like
why did you do it
and
she just gives a reason that doesn't
feel like
the doesn't feel like the reason but it
perfectly makes sense for what's going
on what do you want everyone to take
from this experience and
take from the movie what is the message
that we can take
uh and move forward what
i guess is why you made this in the
first place but what is that
anyone can actually get to that
i mean i i think um
i agree i think everyone has a mother
and i mean i could stop there but here
we are
i think um
i've seen
you know i i
i'm
just about to be 44 next week
and um olive good job
look fantastic and i i've spent you know
my life in this world along with all of
you and i've seen a whole lot of movies
and um
i have so rarely seen myself really
totally honestly like kind of reflected
back at me i have now and then you know
and it's really impactful when i have
like um i i always think about i always
think about the piano you know which um
wide is that image of holly hunter with
her ankle tied to the piano floating in
the bottom of the ocean still stay with
me when i saw that movie when i was 16.
i don't know but
it does it just went in like straight
like water
and you you know in some ways you're
asking like
is this also a movie for men you know i
think as women we've had to sort of
twist ourselves to watch films that were
either about men and we go okay it's not
me but
i can get something from this
or
that had women in them where you go
i don't know i kind of relate to that
but i'm going to twist so i can
understand
and
i actually think
that i spent a lot of my life
not sure if the kind of edges of my
feelings
were normal
because i never saw them or rarely saw
them expressed on screen
um
i think i hope
what i that that here this is not a
movie about someone who's crazy
they're amazing movies there's a whole
like like
genre of movies about powerful crazy
women
you know directed by incredible people
movies i really admire but this is not
that this is a movie about a sane woman
about a few sane women who are getting
into the edges of their feelings
and that the spectrum of what's normal
in terms of being a person in the world
is big
and
so i hope in the same way that when i
read ferrante
and i
first
thought how [ __ ] up some of her
characters were and then realized that
they were mirrors to me
and found that so comforting you know oh
man someone else is writing this down i
must not be the only person thinking
this
um
i hope that my film is comforting in
that same way
to people about the
the huge spectrum of feelings that
we have as human beings in the world
two great lessons learned today maggie
jonah makes great movies and we all have
mothers
uh thank you you're gonna be your
tagline uh you have to use it now it is
like the thing moving forward uh but no
thank you all for joining me and hanging
out with me tonight thank you all for
coming out and please tell everyone to
watch your lost daughter when it comes
out and again maggie dakota peter and
paul
thank you
[Music]
you